thank you Mr chair we have some Civic
students from New Market High
School in the audience
today ladies thank you this isn't going
to be really exciting uh representative
K why don't you just give an idea of
what the bill is about and why we're
here for this meeting right thank you Mr
chair I I have shared some information
with them including the uh the video
that we had a few years ago when we
first began this bill with the uh actor
who portrayed Louis on Sesame Street
advocate ating so carefully for this uh
payroll card idea so what happens is
when you when you have a job and as
we've discussed this they do have jobs
uh you may be paid with a with cash
check or a direct deposit and another
option is a payroll debit card for those
particularly who don't have a bank
account don't want a bank account but or
are unable to have one and this is an
option that is offered uh uh but we want
to we I and our committee has previously
retained wanted to retain the option of
a paper check as that should is a choice
that when someone wants their wages in a
paper check they should have it that's
where we've come down thus
far one of the things that important um
when we make decisions here in this
committee is we have to think about
everybody we have to think about
someone uh you know barely making
$220,000 a year and trying to to just to
stay afloat um and someone making a
whole bunch of money a year we have to
think about big businesses small
businesses um and everyone in between
not just the simple ones you think about
of the grocery store or or whatever
there's a lot of small different one or
two man businesses some things that I
don't even understand some high-tech
stuff that is far above me um so we make
the decisions on these things well this
may be good for one it may not be good
for another exactly so as we come here
today we've had a hearing on the
bill and we listen to testimony from
people who came up to the desk and said
why they want this bill or maybe why
they don't want the bill and sometimes
an hour-long conversation is not
sufficient enough for us to determine
whether or not you know we like it or
whether there are some mistakes in it
where some things that we could change
to make it better because we don't like
to put out things out of this committee
that go to the house floor if they're
not ready
and this one isn't
ready and someone has submitted a
potential Amendment um to make some
changes based on the comments that we
made in the
committee so that's what we're going to
do
today
um as you know I always kind of keep
subcommittees uh more informal um so if
anyone from the Department or anyone
here would like to opine or give give
your opinion on on on on whatever
um now that you've had an opportunity to
kind of look at the amendment um feel
free to just raise your hand and you can
come up and and uh be recognized
um you need the am you have the
amendment I have the amendment yeah are
there any more copies of the Amendments
I had eight you guys have any extra
there there are s okay like why don't
you grab one and then if the other if
your students want to look at it they
can look at it you bring this amendment
no the amendment has been not been
brought okay this was a suggested
amendment by uh the the uh the lobby
firm that uh has been hired by um ADP if
any amendment is something that we would
be agreeable to I'm sure they will have
the prime sponsor representative kofalt
bring it
forth the two issues I believe that we
have on this bill is number
one the ability for someone to still
have the paper check
number
two
the requirements of the
employer to be responsible if the check
card Has a
Glitch uh in the computer system or if
the employee loses or misplaces their
card
um and the
third issue is whether or not this
favors one business over another and
makes it impossible for others to be in
the payroll business those are the three
issues that I have seen is there anyone
else that has any other things that they
they've
noticed yeah we can go on all day but
I'll keep it brief all right
representative
avalani uh who's coming who's the who's
the lucky recipient of
questions um dialogue with the four of
us to discuss oh um so I took it upon
myself to download and find um top five
payall companies um that
would possibly benefit from this going
forward and their list of
fees some I could live with some I could
not um you can you provide us an example
of uh some of the fees that you have
issue with rapid pay card is one company
um they're one of the largest in the in
the country there's five or six of them
that provide pay Woll services and other
things um they charge for cash ACC cash
access at any ring from a $150 to
$3.50 so if you just want to take a cash
deposit off your pay card yep but you
don't know whether it gives you the
first
one for free the first one you get your
paycheck it's 00 for the week um when
you can take that all without a fee yep
they can take the first you have to
that's have a law first transaction each
pay period for those listed with one
free otherwise the card holder which
charge the listed fee so that is one um
that charges a whole host
of things um monthly maintenance fees
was another one on Money Network on top
of other customer service fees inquiry
fees and everything else um also a limit
per day
ATM withdrawal limits $600 per
transaction per day uh $10,000 uh check
limit per day uh transaction limits per
day over the counter of
$8,000 so if you make more than that or
want or we're saving up for something to
go shopping or on a vacation you can't
get you can't get all your money for
free um and then International Banks and
everything else then there was uh pin
pin uh debit transactions was also a
limit 3,000 per day signature debt limit
signature debit transactions which is
part of the um branded Visa Mastercard
is offer signature debit pce I find this
one very interesting to get a
replacement card if the employer
provides it they still charge you $5
even though the employer did everything
if uh it's um replacement card done
by these the the company Rapid pay card
is $10 and 99 now this is not why this
is not wisely that has some kind of
ownership relationship with ADP that the
people that want the bill a bill payment
bill so these are the companies that
would
be I don't want to say benefiting but be
able to enjoy this type of
legislation
and I'm all for reducing employer
overhead but I don't see how this
reduces the employee these fees by
getting a papercheck by getting direct
deposit by getting what we've done for
the last 40 or 50 years when all of this
came about I don't see a problem with
what we have now um there is one in
the uh I did manage to find the wisely
pay
one um which is part of their thing I
did highlight one section that came they
also have plenty of fees as well um
highlighted one section C that was kind
of upsetting to
me um liability for unauthorized
transactions if you do not tell us
within two business days after you learn
over the loss or theft of your card and
we can prove we could have stopped
someone from using your card without
your permission if you had told us you
could lose as much as
$500 how is that beneficial to an
employe to have a pay card forced upon
them by this
legislation
I may they also have an inactivity fee
yes and so if you I don't know change
jobs and you're not getting a paycheck a
pay period every week from that job
maybe you're looking for another job
your money goes away a little little bit
of the time and as you pointed out you
know this isn't just for wisely and
anybody with a payroll card can can do
this and further the payroll cards are
allowed now as an option so I I don't
see uh I mean if I had an opportunity to
prohibit them I I'd probably be looking
at that instead do we know if these fees
that he was just talking about pertain
to the company that
ADP um we kind of went over a number of
different things the first one was not
the wisely company um is um I have the
wisely charges was the one he just
mentioned that one sentence uh about you
could be responsible to $500 if you
don't notify it within 48 hours be lost
of a pay card and then fraudulent use
that's yep and there is one from
Skylight which is also I think is in use
in this state um I know
Amazon possibly um has this through a m
their through their signature MasterCard
they also have um a a bit of fees and
limited on limited on ATM withdrawal
limits of 325 per transactions not to
receed $940 in any 24-hour period how is
that allowing somebody to withdraw all
of their paycheck at
once and I know they've told told us
that you know you don't want to you want
to be cashing a check because you got
all that money you could lose it or be
robbed you know even if you take you one
free bite at the Apple there you are
walking around with your whole paycheck
in
cash people do that now I mean some
people you
know get their check as you know
Employers in New Hampshire must have a
place for you to cash your check for no
fee right so uh they go in there and
they don't have an account there maybe
they don't have a checking account maybe
they don't want a checking account um so
they have to cash it there I remember
this is going back a years guys but I
used to work at a Grand Union I used to
work in the deli in the Grand Union when
I was in high school and uh we got our
paycheck and I had a little savings
account at some local you know Bank
interest trust or whatever so I got my
first paycheck and I was like all right
get my first paycheck I want to go cash
this in my bank and the manager said no
you have to cash it here so you have to
go up to the you know the courtesy desk
and and cash your check I thought that
was now this was a long time ago 40
years ago whatever but um anyway I
digress sorry was there was there a
maximum amount I asked that question I
don't remember what the answer was
remember there was a couple of Maximum
accounts um uh the Skylight has a 5,000
overthe counter cash withdrawal limit so
if you make if you have more than 5,000
in your account you can only get you can
only withdraw it once per day um same
thing with uh transfers account to
account transfer limits not to exceed
four transfers or up to, 1500 in any
24hour period so if you needed to
transfer your mortgage payment over you
wouldn't be able to do that under some
of these options now
I did find the ones that were outside of
New Hampshire and they had different
fees that weren't as um
transparent it looks like some of them
that are here that are in the that are
in the state do offer
zero um your
first withdrawal free and then it adds
in other domestic ATM withdrawals it
doesn't identify which one each
withdrawal after the first withdrawal as
a
$1.75 um
if you go on the website for wisely and
others you will find that legisl
legislators
have um changed
the laws as to when they've implemented
these pay
cards they um put curves into what fees
can be
charged um some have have said that you
can't charge for replacement others so
um it varies by statement what each one
of these companies can charge so I'm
assuming there's no maximum amount that
they can have on the card so let's say
somebody doesn't have a bank account and
they just keep all their money in there
and may live at home don't spend any
money is there a maximum amount that
they of money that they can actually
have on the card itself yes per card per
account is 15,000 on some of them some
of them are 40,000 and some of them are
10,000 okay there is there is a maximum
that you can leave on there um but you
get a fee for keeping it there like
utilizing as kind of a savings account I
I couldn't I couldn't get into that part
of it of their stuff because I wasn't a
customer I but it looks all nice on the
front when it says no fees for this or
that this or that till you turn it over
it was also if he if you wanted to add
money yes there is
595 that is yeah wisely has that some
other ones don't have that option you
have to there was one on here that you
could buy into a program for $10 a month
you could load your own checks into your
card right that you have to buy a
membership fee to change your card
structure right so without being a dead
horse here um it's clear we don't
appreciate the fees right um I'd like to
go through the through the bill and some
of the issues we had with the bill and
then review um this amendment so one of
the first changes of the bill comes on
page one line
10 uh with written authorization of the
employee by direct deposit to Banks to
the employer's choice now I never I
think we asked the question but I don't
remember if we got the answer that we
were really looking for as to why that
was being stricken out is that because
when this was written 10 years ago you
needed uh authorization because it's so
common right now uh there's really no
need for the authorization by the
employeee uh for direct deposit why is
that why was that stricken out that was
my question I I I wonder if it's just
you know they they didn't give you you
didn't give them a payroll card so now
their next option is I'm sorry a a
direct deposit account information so
now the option is payroll card it's
that's in D look at I payroll cards are
already allowed in New Hampshire right
so why was with written authorization
does anyone from the Department of Labor
remember
why they struck that out from the
hearing
I usually write my notes all over it and
I don't recall that we actually got an
answer we did not that's the why so I I
I see no reason to strike that out I I
don't see the purpose um I like there to
be a little bit of written
authorization
um I don't see that there's a harm I
don't see that anyone came and from the
banks and saying we don't need it
anymore or the employers are saying we
don't need it
anymore usually you have to give
authorization because you have to give
them your routing number and account
number so when you're there they might
as well just sign in the dotted line
saying they gave you the information and
it's okay I don't really see any you
know trying to if we're trying to have a
mindset here of moving forward you know
uh to to a newer age with newer
technology I just don't see any reason
why you wouldn't have that because you
you
someone's got to send you an
email or send you something or fill out
a form hand you a check avoided check or
avoided deposit ticket they have to give
you something as an employer you can't
just drop money I can't say okay I just
hired Mike yesterday I'm going to drop
money in this account how how do I how
do I do that without your consent or
authorization so is there any
disagreement as to why that that we
should not strike that
out can can we ask the department how
they enforce that rule if they go in and
do a
audit is direct you guys enforce a
something what they were looking so
avoid a check from an employee in their
file would basically authorize the
employer to direct bonds that's not
employe so we should Define written
authorization then for
not dep language put in it so how would
you how would
you dispose of this if this line was
taken out how would by direct deposit to
the banks of the employees Choice how
would you find that How would how would
you be able
to enforce it enforce
that
Len
Cent and therefore the current bill
would not require um any type of written
authorization that that's what it looks
like they're trying to do here exactly
the way that the inspection unit then
would they would be able to step over
that one aspect of it that used to be in
the law if this passes and look at the
fact that the employee did hand over
whatever information was
required there may be a question as
to um whether the employee was forced to
hand it over because that's the only
option or and that's not something that
I would be able to dig into right now
but if the employee willingly
voluntarily handed over his banking
information for direct
deposit the department would be able to
consenting so if so if you're doing a
regular in fact in in if you you're
called in for a wage claim you would
actually look at this and decide whether
the employee was forced to participate
in direct deposit or would this just be
a because it if the employee made a
comment if there was a statement that
was made that would be further down into
an inspection but looking at it at face
value if an employee again if this
language was
stricken if an
employee offered up their banking
information for direct deposit
with this language being stricken the
department would be able to look at that
during an inspection and be able to
determine that that was probably consent
okay thank you for clarifying anything
further than that would probably require
a hearing I know weren't prepared for
this um it's okay top of your head any
kind of rules that you have in place
regarding this that helps you better the
hearing officer better Define this or
the inspector to better define whether
or not it was authorized in writing by
the employee
yeah I don't believe again I know that
you were prepared for the questions um
and I hav bring my rules I haven't but I
did bring assistance okay yeah off the
top of our head I I don't know if
there's a rule that better defines
written authorization but we can
research that for you okay well is it is
anyone complaining that it's a problem
getting written authorization the
Inspection Division has not notified us
that there has been a problem of maining
authorization okay thank you thank
you
so we don't have any interest in
Striking that
sentence no
no I'm going to go to the next one under
D you can be paid by a payroll card
provided that the employer shall provide
to the
employee at least one free
means has been replaced with the
ability
I don't like that me
neither um
we a Cornerstone of what we do here is
the employee gets their pay without a
fee the ability to withdraw up to
including the full
fee am I missing something nope
that
so now I have to look at the amendment
that we're looking at Amendment C with
written authorization employ we've
already agreed that that is going to
stay
in
um they have somehow I got to figure out
how they've done this
at least one free means okay so in the
in the in the amendment they did put at
okay
okay so then we go down to further down
in
D um their amend M did not address any
of these things so on line 15 starting
with if an employee is enabled to in
ending on line 22 with the words 24
hours being
sentence if an employee is unable to
access their wages due to technical or
processing de deficit the employer shall
immediately provide the wages to the
employee with a replace
debit card check or direct posit or cash
I'm going to just do the first sentence
first and we can deal with the second
right let's think about it from this
standpoint check cards are already legal
people already have them so anything we
do here is we're trying to provide some
kind of protection
or Clarity M as to what should happen
when someone loses their pay
card if they're able to access their
wages due to technical or processing
deficit the employee shall immediately
provide the wages to an employer with a
replacement card debit or whatever I
don't like the word shall
immediately okay for a number of reasons
um that is hard to Define in law
immediately is right now the second
after I just said it that's immediately
one business day the next business day
or if sooner by the if the at the
employer the next business day or sooner
if can be you know by by the employer
something like
that because it's it's tough here
because well no you know I take that
back because this is because wages are
due but not able to because of Technical
and processing deficit
okay def defect
sorry as We Know
you do your pay
right what do you do when someone
doesn't pay the check balances or
whatever you say Department of Labor
what
immediately well you have toine exactly
so what what is it how do how do you you
know someone calls up hi my pay was due
today it's at 3:30 I always get paid and
I got this check card and it's not
working and they say there's a technical
problem or maybe my employer's check
didn't get there on time so there's no
money what are you going to do we going
to call the
employer and
say give him a card right give him give
him a check
then oh you're talking about as far as
what the Department of Labor will do I
thought we were listening to the rest of
the story I apologize no
I'm um so yeah if they call up the
Department of Labor the Department of
Labor the Inspection Division has the op
ability to contact the employer find out
what happened instruct them on the law
which is that they are entitled to their
pay on their payday and uh instruct that
employer to make sure that something is
issued so that employee is paid on that
day whether it be check direct deposit
cash gold and silver so what say you on
how we all agree that if a pay
card craps
out the money is not there for any does
reason
sunspots Verizon going down who knows
anything the money is not
there what do we want to
utilize for a term of when they need to
day 24 hours within 12
hours uh you know what or are you okay
with immediately well I mean business
day if it's the weekend and then you're
not in business that day that's that's
another hardship for the I don't like
that I I as I as I talk myself through
it and out of it I agree the next
business day is not
day I'm just saying the same day you're
supposed to get if the money's not there
in your pay card my opinion m
me a check yeah or cash right now and I
want to say immediately because it
immediately is within a second well
that's
not right you got to give them a couple
hours maybe to figure out what the
problem is maybe the system reboots
itself and and two hours later it's
there so that's why I said that the same
day don't even say business day because
Saturday and Sunday someone's check is
due on a Saturday right and it's not
day we get paid the big bucks for I
don't like it at all but this is to
protect the employee if the employer has
deposited their pay into a pay card and
whether it is the ATM or the car that is
no longer working having the employer on
hook for sending that paycheck to the
pay card now having to have them send a
second week's pay to that employee you
have you're forcing the employer to
possibly pay them twice in the same day
or week when some employeers might not
have that kind of cash on hand or they
might use a sweep account where they
can't sweep account till the next day or
they use a private company that might
not be open Saturday or Sunday to
authorize that transfer how do we
protect the employer as well as the
employee by act with this type
of language I'm assuming this has
happened with debit cards in the past
where you may
have $10,000 in the bank you go to an
ATM and for whatever reason your card
fails right you can't get you can't get
cash on the weekend sure what's
happening you're not going to call
you're not going to get a hold of
anybody at the bank nope figure it out
it's going to be on the next business
day
so I would like to know
how they resolve those problems because
again I don't think it's I mean it's it
can't it's got to
happen how about if we break it down to
specifics if an employee is unable to
access their wages due to a defective
card that way you're talking about a
defective card this you know because you
can call the system says no the money's
there everything's fine you're defective
card then they must immediately provide
a replacement card check or
cash breaking it down to the scenario we
have a defective
card you okay with that no okay why so
if the if the like you said if you can
call in and the money is there the
employer paid them the employeer
followed the law right if they can't
access their card because of a defect
why should the employer have to issue
them a check when they've already paid
them how about a replacement card
replacement card yes but everybody
charges six to 10 or $20 and then fees
to get it EXP Ed or overnight delivery
your employee is not going to have some
of these don't offer
employer issued
cards so how would an employee be able
to do that gentleman from ADP said it
would be an issue as well if it was a
Saturday because no way that ADP works
I'm not going to I can issue you a card
sure I can give you a card it's not
going to be connected to anything until
let's look at the second
sentence okay since we none of us like
the way the first sentences were down
and I'm looking to protect the employee
here MH okay to get their
money they got to pay their bill they
got to put gas in their car they got to
have their money second sentence if an
employee debit card is lost stolen or
damaged such the funds are no longer
accessible to the employee the employer
shall provide the employee with a
replacement employee debit card within
notified is that an
acceptable so we're adding another layer
of buau ocy to an employer because they
choose pay cards which they some of
these don't offer the ability for the
employer to hand their employee A card
without some type of processing with the
payroll card provider their bank and
possibly a third party that would load
that
card but all you're asking to do is
replace provide another card if they
lose their card L know whether it's
their fault or not if they choose to
take
use a a payroll card they're going have
to pay the fee correct but it's within
24 hours of being notified if I'm
notified at 6 o'clock on a Friday I
can't provide them with a card till
Monday well you probably will because
you get a you get
a um the way these things work MH is you
get this card reader mhm M okay and you
got all these blank cards you ever go to
the get a get a gift card for Christmas
you pick up one of the pretty ones
Dunkin Donuts and you take it and you
hand it the guy and say to $25 on this
and they swipe it and they put the thing
in well that's what you would do as an
employer correct if that if that certain
Payroll Company offered that there are
other ones out here that do not but all
you're saying is so you're saying what
happens if I don't have I don't have
those okay so you're in your example you
have a CPA that does your payroll right
and if the CPA is closed on the weekend
mhm and they're the ones that have the
the cards and they do all that you're
going to say you're not going to be able
to buy by that it would be impossible
because they're closed all right I'm
going to play Devil's Advocate because
that's what we do here what are we going
to do about the employee that needs his
pay I'm we're going on how this is
written not in a h hypothetical because
I'm happy to give them their pay if they
can't access their card how but they
need I would pay them however they need
to be paid but I don't want to be forced
into a box Bo by forcing to pay them
twice if the employee comes to me and
says hey I can't access my car blah blah
blah I we're going away this weekend all
right here's a check you know when you
get back we'll settle
up that would be that's
how as a small employer I would do I
know large employers can't do that but
when you have a card that's no longer
functional the money is in that account
in cyberspace M okay the card's not
working to grab it out of space you give
them a new card the money is still there
in cyberspace and goes to the new card
you're not paying them twice correct
well what's the difference between a
direct deposit into your account that
account you going to go to your employer
and say I want a new card because I
can't access my wages that's not that's
the bank's problem with their debit card
should be the payroll company's problem
by not letting them access their money
with debit with check cards it does not
become the check card company's problem
it becomes the employer problem who is
utilizing the payroll cards they've
taken that
responsibility that that's what they're
going to do to use the payroll
cards so all I'm saying is if the
employer as this is written right now we
haven't got into the other part well the
responsibility is all thrown away I'm
that's that's that's a fat of comp
that's leing but just what I'm trying to
do here without getting too tough here I
I want PE right now we have aw we have a
law that allows you to use pay cards M
we have no
law that tells
you you got to pay
somebody if your card is lost or stolen
or damaged and they can't get access to
their funds what if the card is not lost
or stolen or damaged and they can't
access their funds because of a
technical problem on from from from one
of these other companies outside of the
employ
responsibility well what will happen
is guy called you get paid on Thursday
the guy calls you Friday says I my my my
card's not working I I slide I slide I
slide it's not working come into the
office you look on the screen you get a
new
card
if the money if the problem is with the
pay card
vendor you the employer didn't do
anything wrong you provided them a new
card M to access their money in
cyberspace you've done your job you
you've adhered to the law how would the
department look at that because I'm I'm
as I'm reading this the Department's
going to be knocking on their door
saying hey you need to pay this guy you
can't access his funds 24 hours what are
they doing now yeah what's your
experience been with payroll
cards very minimal actually minimal
experience we've had um we've had some
calls about complaints that came from
both the employees and the
employers um but there's only been a
couple of them where there's been an
issue with respect to um being paid
correctly and those are a little
different situation those are more with
the daily cards that they have where
they have U paid by daily I'm not even
going to get into that but your question
there one to hear that yeah I thought so
um your question about what would happen
in a situation like that it the employer
remains responsible for making sure that
that employee is paid receives his pay
and has access to his pay on his payday
and anything after that could be subject
to number one a Heering to a potential
violation um in a situation where
there's uh an issue with the pay card
the employer's responsibility does not
go away that doesn't change you can't
shift that responsibility to a pay card
company that's a discussion you can have
with the pay card company but it's not a
shift of
responsibility as far as if you were to
have a pay card that was not operational
and you're concerned rightfully so
making two payments now you have one
payment sitting on a pay card and one
payment that you're going to have to
make Maybe by check by cash by direct
deposit you also have under Section 48
where you can get a writing the employee
and the employer agree in writing to
terms of repayment of an overpayment and
this can be done at the same time as
you're handing them their replacement
check at that time so you would put in
it can't be any more than 20 % of the
gross pay that would normally be taken
you know each week um there are
limitations to it but the employee can
in writing agree to doing that and so
the employer would then have the ability
to be
reimbursed if there was an overpayment
there's also the possibility and I don't
know if any of those cards have the
ability to cancel out an amount if
you're handing them a check that's
something worth considering I'm not sure
if that would work though if it's paid
later than the day of payday I don't
want to get into um the double payment
right now okay because there's no way
we're going to solve that today there's
no way we're going to work oursel
through all the different scenarios
here if the next 15 minutes if we can't
come up with something then we're just
going to you know not agree to this
entire Amendment here or this entire
portion of the bill I'm concerned with a
card that is damaged you know you ever
you you put a pay card up to the back of
a cell phone you know what happens you
ever been to a hotel and your card
doesn't work in the hotel because it was
next to your cell phone it demagnetized
itself it
happens um so you know somehow my card
got demagnetized so the strips not
working I just want a new card don't we
think the employee should be have have
access to a card with a new card if it's
just a lost stolen or whatever because
if it's l lost or stolen it doesn't
matter the money is still sitting in the
cloud it's just a the card is just a
mechanism to get it so giving them a new
card allows them to access it has
nothing to do with if it's the the
payroll
company doesn't have the funds there or
something like that it's just a new card
that's all I'm trying to get at do we
think there should be a certain specific
amount of time upon the employee let's
say it's not even payday let's say it's
five four days after payday okay and
your card's not working
okay should you be able to get a new pay
card within within 24 hours I think you
should it cost you $30 okay well that's
that's the choice the employer made with
the employee when they decided to use
the damn
things but none of the this last
sentence none of the employer costs asso
with associated with the payable card or
payroll account should be passed on to
the employee would that be passing on
the cost of a a payment card to to the
employee by having it overnighted from
delivery I would assume that we could in
language that would have to come out
coming up with this bill figuring it out
if the fees are the problem I mean do we
come out with something that says
there's no fees to the
employee I mean I was actually going to
talk to my comrade over here here and
tell him to bring that up because it's
the biggest poison pill you've ever seen
on the piece of legislation ever fine no
fees
ever I'm sure the sponsors won't
appreciate that but that is I go to the
bank with my debit card or I go to the
store I'm not getting charged fees for a
debit card then I you
know that's the key right there because
they fee you from having the checking
account to begin with well he pay me
Interest that's true um so so yes that
would be um that is actually something
that we could state that no fees can be
passed on to the employee well obviously
it in a business from a business
standpoint a non-starter then no one
would do it no pay card companies would
engage in
that well again I think if this is an
option for
employers and
it's difficult by lot with a lot of
things that are going to come down on
the
employer a lot of employers may decide
that they don't want to use the pay
cards as a means and stay with direct
deposit and I guess I'm I'm looking for
what the advantage of the pay card is um
overall that's I guess I I haven't found
that and if somebody has an answer for
that that would be great I mean I
cheaper than I guess a $20 as they
estimate the cost to process a check per
pay period does it cost anything for I
mean loo you have a business direct
deposit is there
anything minimal okay 22 cents if
anything to initiate an a I was talking
to representative Ross Barry before he
came up here and he uses TD
Bank and um for direct deposit and I
think it's like $5 a month whether he
has one employee or three
00 he pays one fee of $500 a month to
have all his employees receive direct
deposit yeah we pay a flat weekly
fee is the employer getting fees on
these cards I mean that he has to pay he
or she has to pay
um I've never I've never used
them I'm sure there's a fee guarantee
there's a fee there's a fee to use any
payroll company they have to get paid
right right to to provide a
service
but their I think their point is it's
cheaper for the
employee excuse me it's cheaper for the
employer than the cost of a
check process check get it done FedEx it
over you know yeah yeah so the people
is people that don't have direct deposit
that may not have a bank account in
general they're going to go with these
cards well that's or they're going to
get a papercheck can I be really blunt
sure payroll cards are used for a lot of
people that are receiving compensation
it I mean you take advantage of someone
that that comes to immigrates here
illegally
and they're working just to feed
themselves you know if you're going to
do
that pay them cash I don't if you're
going to choose to do that as an
employer that's fine I'm not going to Pi
any dispersions on you but at least pay
him cash don't give him one of these
things and I think some people I mean
93% according to their own figures 93%
of the people get direct deposit in this
state mhm okay so we're talking about 7%
of 750,000 people that are employed
that's 49 50,000 people that we're
talking about here
um
so
um I I I don't like it because I think
it's a
mechanism I'm showing my age here right
remember the old days when you used to
go to the airport mhm cash a check no to
go to the airport to cash a check well
the no but you go to the airport and
they actually actually gave you some
service now I go I put my own stuff in I
get my own tag I buy the whole thing and
I bring it up M oh and if and then
you're going to charge me $25 if you
want you to do it so I don't you do it
yourself I mean think about all the
things that we have done in this country
where we used to provide services
employeers used to provide services and
now you selfs Serve Yourself Mr chairman
I'm surprised because if you fly first
class they do that
all so I would assume you fly first you
don't fly first
class I don't fly
sometimes but I flew last week on spirit
in the first class seats up front but
anyway um it's just a
don't I don't like the inference of why
card and I think sometimes you have to
think why doesn't someone want a
checking
account well there are some fees I don't
like them either you know I probably pay
10 or 12 bucks a month to have a
checking account at at my bank so
um you know why doesn't someone want a
checking
account okay that's their choice but at
least if they get a check they go to the
place that they choose where they can
get it
free they don't have to have a checkm
account
mhm and I I don't think we should
legislature that you can be forced
check I'm in circles here let's get back
to what we're doing here I want to go
back just a few more years uh to where
you would go to a bank drawn on that
bank and they would not charge you $7 to
cash it because you don't have an
account
there but uh Credit Unions generally
don't do that and they also don't have
those wacky monthly balances things um I
don't like the idea that you have that
the check in this amendment has to be
upon request okay I I like I like it
like here's here's your meth methods you
can choose which one is best for you and
if the check is on that list and it
should be then that's what I want to do
so line 15 starting with the words if an
employee and line 22 ending with being
notified we don't like any of it I don't
I don't like the whole thing
24e um there is a two lines that are
crossed out I'd like you to turn to the
amendment um
where they have added a few other lines
here take a second to look at it uh cuz
I um can't see where they're trying to
inject this thing I don't know if it's a
whole brand new e or not doesn't no
there if I may yes they're making it
that the employee has to request a check
right um from a from b c and d the
default was always if you didn't get
their direct deposit information if you
couldn't initiate an EFT to something
that they were using um the default was
always issuing them a check because they
did not provide the information right
um further down in this that we haven't
got to yet takes that away and makes it
a request of the employee so it's not an
automatic default of people who may not
have or companies that may not have
access to payroll cards which is your
smaller local CPAs little little payroll
firms that do um all the all your you
know you know maybe don't have access to
payroll
cards um this would make them if it
passed
non-compliant by not being able to offer
payall cards in sections further down in
this bill which we'll get
to and then I'm going to ask the
department how they would take care of
that go ahead because I'm confused so
read
so further down in the
Bell um page
24 a paywall company that does not have
access to paywall cards in absence an
of banking information to have their
direct deposit initiated would be forced
to pay by a payroll card would that be
[Music]
correct in the way that the bill is
MH
there I'm sorry guys I haven't eaten yet
figure the language is uh verbose but um
I think the answer is likely yes
that question would they be forced into
paying with the pay card it was page two
part yeah 21 through yes um If an
employer that wishes to only offer
electronic wage payments so they don't
want to have checks they can offer b c
and d let's just
say there would be forced with in the
consent to a payroll card so you have my
payroll company doesn't offer let's say
a pay company doesn't offer payroll
cards but they offer now BC and
E by changing the wording in
E would be forcing them smaller pay
companies who do not have access to
payroll cards being out of compliance
with this if they pay company does not
employee how would the department look
at that payroll company and saying
you're no longer in compliance because
you cannot offer payroll cards and
effectively possibly putting them out of
business or forcing them into a contract
with the payall card company outside of
their
jurisdiction a lot it's okay there the
only way to get
there I mean fundamentally at the end of
the day the respon responsibilities on
the employer to to pay what regardless
of their arrangement with the payroll
company they have to be able to provide
that pay without any cost to the
employees or any fee to the employees so
no matter how how the employer and the
payroll company uh arrange that that
ultimately when it comes to an
enforcement action um that potential
employer so if my one of my employees
said Okay I want I I'm not giving you my
payroll information I'm not giving you
my bank
information with the changes that are
here now defaulting to a payroll card my
companyes let's just say my company
doesn't offer payroll
cards they they go to you guys and say
well he's not giving me a payroll card
even though I'm entitled to it by law
what's going to happen to that employer
and that payroll company pay company
going to get fined because they're out
of compliance possibly by not the do but
maybe somebody else
and what is the employer going to be on
the hook
for so it would be the employer election
on how they wish to pay if the employee
doesn't offer payroll cards then they
don't have to as is the current law yes
but with this change shall pay tells me
as an employer I have to pay by payroll
card in absence of and he didn't request
a pay for check MH now I'm forced to pay
yes employ offers its employees the
option of receiving wages by payroll
cards so if the employer is not offering
that option and they've elected some
other payment you could arguably say
that the requirements to pay via payroll
card um would not fall under that
umbrella um um if the employee is not
providing the direct deposit that being
said if you're looking at provision to
the kind of Standalone it does look like
it makes a mandate that in the absence
of that information being provided
that's going to be the default for the
employer so I think if there's any the
language may need to be cleaned up if
there's any intent to go forward with
that I think you could arguably say that
if the employer doesn't option offer the
option at all to to pay the a payroll
card then the provisions of 2B in the
proposed language would not
apply but again I I it's not I don't
think it's terribly clearly drafted I
don't again the warning is very strong
in paragraph B but if you're reading it
in conjunction with the opening
paragraph of two
um I think you can construe it that way
and I'll defer to attorney garan if he
thinks my reading is a that was a much
more elegant way of saying what I was
trying to say it was but if the upon if
um e in the in the original proposed
language not in the amendment yes in the
out so now what default from okay I only
offer uh EFT or
direct deposit so I only offer
electronic means we don't have checks we
haven't used checks in 20 years we're
you know we're with the time so we're
whatever now it's telling me I have to
pay by payroll card in absence of Bank
information because the default of
having of being able to write a check
because I don't have Bank information is
withdrawn because the employee has to
consent to having a
payable uh being cut a live
check whether it's in in here or in the
amendment either
way I think that that that initiating
clause in section two I'm looking at
this is the original Bill page two line
five puts a conditional clause on if the
employee if the employer offers its
employees the option of receiving wages
by payroll card so if that's not an
anyway
all right so do we pretty much agree
that we do not like U the changes on
lines 26 through
Bill oh I
don't Crossing all that out you don't
agree to it I don't I don't like that oh
nor do I do we all agree we do not want
that crossed out we do not
okay I want to jump to page two lines
three and four nothing in this section
prohibit an employee or organization
labor group negotiating the method of
employer is there any problem with that
not they going to pass a bill just for
that sentence but
is I don't think anybody should be cared
out why should a private employer who
doesn't have Union
coverage be forced to abide by a
CBA they do on a lot of things they do
but we carve them out on a lot of things
when we we're talking about payment of
wages why should they be upheld to a
different standard than everybody else
because that that if that's what the
contract negotiators come up with with
the
employer just saying we're carving out
that specific
part
of W uh people that people that have
wages what do they do with their wage
claims they go to the CBA or they go to
the
labor you understand where where he's
trying to be consistent y
okay um well if that's the only thing we
agree on we may not just pass the Bill
we'll we'll wait and
see um going down to lines 16 through
24 uh which is what you just talked
about
right
um we're not in favor of that oh no okay
and now all that
removement
correct so getting down to line 27 and
[Music]
um so again they they want to take out
the that the employee voluntarily
consents and make it a mandatory
issue from the employer from I read it
from B going into C starting in part one
I mean they interconnect to forcing an
card so now look at the
amendment page
two in
bold has failed to provide I'm trying to
see what the difference is fa to provide
they need that in order to force the
payments okay it's the same thing okay
except they added an employee request a
B okay so someone that gets a
check if they don't have a bank account
now would have to go to the bank that
maybe the business is doing banking with
right for no fee because I think if you
go
to I don't even know because I haven't
dealt with checks in so long can they
even go to another bank to cash a check
that they don't have an account with you
no it's one they can go to any Bank
probably show their ID and pay a fee a
lot of banks still don't like to do that
so it's difficult which is why they must
provide a bank or a place for them to do
it for
free you can go to a supermarket yeah
Supermarket Walmart but you're all
you're going to pay a fee at all those
places I think it's minimal still that's
another option well there's check
cashing companies and or you could have
your certificant
other who does have a bank account
cash well I had when I the last time I
had live checks um bank my bank um they
could go to my bank and they would
automatically cash in that was our
relationship because that's where the
check was drawn off that's and it was
you know Regional blah blah blah the
whole thing so it wasn't it didn't never
came up as an
issue so now okay line 32 on page
two and instead to receive wages via
direct
deposit the proposed amendment would be
the
same instead to receive wages via direct
deposit or paper
check
By
Request Oh by request at any time
without penalty to the
employee that's that's and that's how we
would do it now if they wanted to go
from paper check to a direct dep
positive and we wouldn't be able to
charge them any fees or if they want to
come out of direct deposit and they were
moving and one of the paper check for a
couple weeks till they move to their new
house or something but see this provides
the employee the ability to say I don't
want it anymore right as they can
anyways no
yes provided the employee the part the
whole part
D now they're mandating direct deposit
or pay to check instead of whatever they
want whether it be an em transfer or
anything else
okay all right e lines 34 through
37 the employer shall provide employees
um
yeah they all do that in here wisely ATM
whatever they have so is this fine would
this be fine to add to the current law
for the people that are already using
the cards do you have a comment the only
thing that I would look at on this one
is the consistency we're talking payroll
card and the rest of the the law and the
first bill is introduced does have
inconsistencies whereas those are
removed in the amendment but if this is
a part of the bill that you would want
to keep in here then I would just change
debit cards to payroll card correct just
for
consistency I'm just saying you know we
can kill it we can we can amend it
um some people don't mind lines three
and four on page two lines 34 35 36 37
do they provide some kind
of
necessary wording that allows people to
utilize their payroll cards and find a
place to cash it for
free um since since payroll cards are
already being
used it's in there whoever there is they
have domestic and
ATM right but that's not New Hampshire
law that's the fees associated with
it I don't think anywhere it say they
need to find a place where they can draw
down their entire payroll card or
disclosures I think e
is
incorrectly what was the question oh
sorry I'm looking at lines 34 through 37
right wondering they should be out of
the
lawani seems to think that's covered in
lines 7 through 15 on page
two under two
him what I'm seeing in lines 11 and
12 is disclosure issues with regards to
fees but it doesn't tell you where you
can get um no no use of a payroll card
that has an expiration
date and and provision of a replacement
payroll card before an expiration date
at no cost the
employee I I don't see specific language
in here that I would interpret that
department would interpret as
ordering the disclosure of a list of
locations where the payroll card can be
fees that would be if I yeah that would
be part of the fee structure within the
card holder agreement that you would
sign with any of these people you would
have all your fees instruction of where
you can go without having another
section of law that tells you you have
again New Hampshire law though requires
an employee to be able to get their
payroll without having to pay a fee so
even if there is a fee that's associated
with any of these particular thirdparty
companies that have the pay cards they
can have whatever fees they want to but
there should it it should be clear that
the law currently stands is that there
should be no fees correct but it's it's
in their C holder agreement which every
employee would sign with whomever
authorizes their payroll
cards I don't see where you're going
that that New Hampshire law supersedes
an agreement with a pay card fee yeah
but you would get this whole stack of
paper with your pay card when you sign
up for your pay card and sign on to ADP
or but it doesn't tell you where you can
get your your debt your your payroll
card
you withdraw your funds with no fee it
does it tells you when here it's their
ATM
people what happens if they don't I mean
these are some that do all of them have
access to uh domestic ATM withdrawals
all point is one of them star is another
one three or four different vendors that
have debit and pay card uh
availability all have have it in their
that's
only right there's other ones that have
it over the I mean we went through all
that earlier how much you can and can't
some of them do have over the counter
limits including banks have over counter
limits so the Hamp law really trunp
banking
think
correct
out
understood I just
want no no I'm just so I have one thing
to
add and I say this with absolutely no
disrespect to anybody but when we heard
this legislation
originally I'm just trying to figure out
is this a problem in the state or is
this legis islation
that somebody could make money by
selling these debit cards to companies
because honestly when we had the public
hearing I didn't see companies lined up
at the door to either say they like this
or they don't like it so I mean is this
I guess that's where I'm at is this a
problem here or is it something that I
mean and I have no isues either way but
trying to understand the whole thing
it's May I think we're confused in the
situation and if I mean if it's not an
issue and I've always said this with
legislation if it's not an issue I mean
I think we're trying to fix something
that's not broken so 97% 93% according
to all the information people get their
things through direct deposit I'm sure
there's people that are U utilizing the
uh the payroll
cards um is it a way for the employer to
save money Poss on expenses through
payroll services
sure um could it be convenient to
certain
businesses uh especially businesses
where their employees maybe it's a New
Hampshire employer and they're all over
the
country okay and and or there people you
know in New Hampshire company that has
people on a oil rig out and go to Gulf
of Mexico then payroll card could be
uh easy uh maybe at a foreign country if
they have employees maybe it could be
easy for those things so there's a lot
of reasons that a payroll card is
Justified and and accepted by certain
employees
um we already have on the law the
ability to use
it to kind of force something on someone
I don't no you're right I don't think
it's a problem that needs to be uh
thrust upon
someone I was trying to take a couple of
the good things out of here and I don't
have a problem with lines 34 through 37
I mean um we can we can amend the bill
we can pass the bill as is or we can uh
itl the bill uh I thought it was very I
think it's a good
exercise um that we can tell um the rest
of our committee that we looked into
this in in a lot of detail and a lot of
had good conversation on it uh and then
you can all explain to your your fellow
members your
thoughts um on it and I all I was trying
to do is try to be as impartial as I
could to try to just go through every
single thing what the changes are how
the the department would act to it uh
and if there's anything that we felt um
could be needed
um I think 34 3567 is is very good for
the
employee I don't have a problem with
lines three and four uh about organized
uh labor if they choose to
um I think organized labor is pretty
smart I think organized labor probably
has everybody doing uh direct
deposit so um those are the things I
think that we can see there the the
parts about making the the you know some
of these other things we just you know
are definitely non-starters for us so um
you know I will leave up to the
committee this this group as to what you
want to do is there is there going to be
any recommendation out of this committee
uh the subcommittee at this point uh or
is it just
um uh are we just going to leave it as
uh no recommendation and you can discuss
it with your uh fellow uh committee
people when we have the executive
session your choice is uh it's up to
whatever you guys would like to do Mr
chairman I would I would respectfully
move itl in the
entire all right all right we do have a
motion I'd support that represent kill
second
it any further discussion even the
amendment leaves me at unrest this is
it's obviously I hate to say one company
but this is obviously a way to Sho pay
cards in as a default instead of a paper
check exactly given the amount of fees
given the way that um swipes are done um
good amount to a
large profitability to some of these
companies under the guys of saving money
for the employer on the backs of the
employees kind of like baging your own
lugage or doing your own check out at uh
certain places I did that last night I
wondered why I did it did you ask him if
they have off few work on compliation
you throw your back out lifting those
potatoes on on the
belt so we have a motion in the second
any additional no
comments uh I I think the you know the
uh law already requires that
people get their pay without fee so and
I think the those who have cards or bank
accounts or employers provide the
information so I don't think we need to
add those lines at the bottom you know
go